and next up a very popular way to learn
maths we'll be talking to mr. Wu tube
Eddie whoo to you well how are you at
math see any good do you remember your
maths teacher when you're at school
Eddie whoo is the head mathematics
teacher a cherry brook tech mill and
technology high school in north west
sydney he's also known as mr. Wu tube he
created the internet sensation whoo tube
which recently won him a national
Teaching Award have a little listen what
was the very first topic that we started
this year do you remember antigen
perfect now do you remember I made a big
deal about the name integers and it had
a meeting right what was it what worth
why integers called into duty above it
there is a whole number exactly right an
integer right where we get to an
integral from which means you know all
in one piece not falling apart it means
whole okay and now we are looking at
fractions I think you guys can do a
pretty good job here I'm gonna ask you
to do this on your own for a second I
want you to write down a definition for
fractions are okay and I expect you'll
get a few different ones okay but I want
you to write down because I know you've
met these before I want to see what
kinds of meanings definitions give me a
sentence what is a fraction well how
about that that's a all sounds like
everyone is very much engaged with mr.
woo Eddie whoo is their head mathematics
teacher as I say it share ebook kick
high school joins me now hello there
Eddie good morning Wendy yes well give
em what you've been doing incredibly
well with his word to buy was looking
online there lots and lots of topics and
and yo case presented in a fun and
engaging way one of the things I was
looking at was a you were explaining try
factors and we're using I think the
analogy of lames in a swimming pool or
something absolutely I mean for me
making sure that mathematics is engaging
and connected to the real world is one
of the things that students
teachers love best to do so trying to
bring that to the masses as much as we
can so how many woo tubes do you have
well I started out just previous videos
up really actually just for a single
student and that's where it began and to
my surprise a lot of other students
students from other classes students
from the schools and then teachers
actually became interested so I put up
videos in a couple of different places
one that's aimed at just regular
students in the classroom and one that's
more aimed at teachers and equipping
them yeah and you have about 20,000
followers now yeah it's I'm as surprised
as anyone else that it's been so you
know well taken up but I think that
speaks to the fact that people really do
want to learn and are willing to put in
the work if they can have an entry into
a subject into a topic that engages them
it and make sense to them and even more
than that Eddie two million hits here
and overseas two million people looking
at your youtubes about maths who knew
it's a when when i first started having
a look at and preemies things up I
thought I actually I really didn't think
anyone would book which is why people
sent to me aren't you self-conscious
about you know putting a camera up in
the middle of your classroom and
everything you say and my answer is well
I never was because I never saw that
many people with attention but I think
the fact that it's just it's a real
classroom and it's exactly what my
students get day to day is one of the
reasons why people get you know this is
down to earth it's um it's honest that
it's it open so any we're looking at the
kids my daughter is one they started HSC
today next year's graduating lot and a
percentage of students learning maths
for the New South Wales higher school
certificate has fallen to its lowest
level in 50 years it's a bad about
seventy seven point six percent it was
about ninety-five percent 30 years ago
what's going on do you reckon well this
is a whole bunch of different factors I
mean one of the things that I think is
the most apparent is a lot of students
are sort of foregoing mathematics
because partly they don't see the need
for it as they leave school
a lot of degrees used to list
mathematics as a prerequisite for study
or even people who weren't going into
you know tertiary studies university
that kind of thing recognized that
mathematics is a really cool part of
just being a normal functioning citizen
who can understand the world around us
and I think that image is kind of sort
of steadily declined over the years and
so people are sort of doing the smart
thing in terms of trying to maximize
well now it's their 8r and thinking well
if I can you know go into a subject
which maybe doesn't require as much
effort mathematics is incredibly
practical you can't just do it by you
know absorbing it passively you've got
to practically get your hands dirty and
if I can you know get a subject that
will get me a good mark and not have to
put in that incredible mental effort
then I'll go for that so I think that's
one of the big things that's contributed
to that decline and what is the answer
well I think that you know it's a bit of
a mirage to be honest to think that we
can sort of forego mathematics I mean
obviously I'm biased but all around me I
can see numbers and patterns and
relationships that being able to
understand mathematics and not being
afraid of it even if there's something I
don't understand immediately I have the
the tools and the attitudes to be able
to approach this water around me
understand it make good decisions so I
think students and teachers and parents
or really need to get a handle on that
and understand hey this is this is
important for everyone everyone needs to
be numerous in the same day that
everyone needs to be literate that's
just an expectation in today's society
so I think sort of changing that
cultural attitude is really important
and there's a disparity to is in there
between girls and boys studying maths
and the at the intermediate level at
eighteen percent girls and 20.5 percent
boys we see that changing at all Eddie
well i hope i hope that there's a lot of
change in the offing i know that there's
lots of harm it's lots of initiatives
I'm involved in some of them that are
specifically aimed at sort of equipping
girls and making sure they understand
they're just as capable as the boys I
think that sometimes
um some of the girls that we teach
sometimes will sort of our away from
thinking oh this is is a bit of a
reputation that it's a boy subject and
even that can be a bit of a turn-off but
I think that's a it's a mistake i mean
this year in fact i'm teaching a
mathematic extension to year 12 class
that's about to do their exams in the
next couple of weeks for the HSC and
some of my finest students the most
diligent the most creative and
thoughtful students are the girls and so
everything we can do to encourage them
and make sure they can see their path
forward as mathematicians or engineers
or any other profession where
mathematics touches that we want them to
be able to see hey there's a future here
for you and so don't give up when you
want me teacher excellence award at the
australian mathematical science
Institute's national choose math Awards
well congratulations there Eddie very
kind of you yeah and know what's winning
the award meant to you has it been for
your career in teaching it's been to be
honest it's quite astonishing to have so
much attention sort of drawn toward us
because to be honest I think I can speak
for most teachers in that we don't want
to single ourselves now we enjoy being
in the classroom being with our our fur
distance in front of us and you know
making sure they just get the best
learning experience they can you're on
year and that's what really matters to
us so I think it's just been kind of a
really nice thing to have the hard work
that all teachers do recognized and
valued I think that education and
schooling is often something that's a
bit thrown around a bit like a political
football sometimes and people forget is
just like in many other fields there's
people who are working hard every day to
make sure the next generation is
equipped and skillful and yet encouraged
to pursue all of the different
capabilities and potential that they how
are you son brilliant you and what about
the kids at cherrybrook and do they do
they mind being on the word tube I've
quite funny I think I'm every every
class that I teach the first time I am I
literally have just an iPad that sits on
top of a tripod in the middle of my room
is connected to a microphone and right
at the beginning the year if there's a
student in my class or students in my
class you haven't experienced before it
kind of little weeded out now they
always ask me sir
thank you my voice and I say yes no it
can't and they sort of a little bit
cautious but very rapidly I mean this is
a this is a selfie kind of you know
self-broadcasting generation they very
quickly realized it's no big deal it's
about the learning and if I some of them
are quite tickled pink you know their
friends who who will contact them and
say hey I heard you know mr. Wu and he
was talking about you you mentioned your
name in common yeah that's because i was
talking to you know quite honestly yeah
and I guess the idea and I love this
Eddie is that people who just want that
bit of extra tuition maybe they fall
behind in class or they're sick or
they're away or whatever they can jump
on the old woud tube and catch up
absolutely I mean I can't even remember
what I had for breakfast two weeks ago
let alone some complex mathematical
concept I learned two months or two
years ago and so it's really just a
great resource I've found for the
students to dip into for teachers to dip
into just sometimes just to get another
perspective you know I'm not the
definitely not like the smartest
mathematician or even as far as math
teacher out there but I just have my own
way of explaining things and sometimes
you just want another angle on an idea
or a concept or a skill well brilliant
and people should check in and YouTube
they go to youtube yeah of course and
then they just put in mr. Wu tube yep
you'll find me up right at the top yeah
okay well brilliant well done you thanks
so much for joining us Eddie and a good
luck with all your HSC students in their
exams when are they starting yes sir the
first exams begin on thursday and my 32
days begin next week yes and as i
mentioned earlier my daughter's just
started she's one of the graduating
she'll be graduating next year so she's
just started her year and a bit today
that's exciting best of luck to our yeah
been feeling very very grown up good on
you thanks so much for joining us Eddie
well it was a pleasure anywhere we had
mathematics teacher at cherrybrook
technology high school and yes something
I guess for HSC students who are
starting on Thursday
maybe you can go and do a little bit of
a brush up on a few a few basic midst of
knowledge I suppose at Sur at word cheap
go and check it out it's good